you ever look up at a banana tree even  though it's not a tree and just you've  never in your life seen a banana tree  why are you talking like staten island  is riddled with banana trees  did you ever look i've been overseas  i've been in hawaii please back me up on  this did you ever look up a bit of  banana tree he makes it sound like he's  talking about a christmas tree he makes  it sound like this is a common  occurrence  in my life a hundred times what are you  talking about okay what are you talking  about i'm not on staten island okay not  in new york so no i've never seen a  banana run on vacation or to a tropical  area yeah i'm sorry if i could only  afford vacations inside the country  i've never been to uh israel or wherever  you saw your bananas where are the  bananas where did you see them what i  said israel where did you see it